>> Jon: WELCOME TO "THE DAILY
SHOW"!
I'M JON STEWART!
MY GUEST TONIGHT ONE ANGELINA
JOLIE, DIRECTOR OF THE NEW FILM,
IT'S GREAT "UNBROKEN".
BUT FIRST, I WANT TO APOLOGIZE
FOR YESTERDAY.
I BEGAN THE SHOW SOMEWHAT
OVERWROUGHT BECAUSE NO ONE
INVOLVED IN THE DEATH OF ERIC
GARNER WAS NEVER INDICTED.
AND I WANT TO APOLOGIZE BECAUSE
I WAS WRONG.
>> THE PERSON WHO DID THE
VIDEOGRAPHY OF THIS.
>> YES.
>> THAT PERSON
WAS INDICTED BY A GRAND JURY IN
STATEN ISLAND OVER GUN CHARGES.
>> Jon: GET IT? SOMEONE WAS
INDICTED. THEY GOT
THE SHOOTER... OF THE VIDEO...
LET THAT BE A LESSON TO YOU KIDS
OUT THERE.
PHOTOGRAPHING CRIME DOES NOT
PAY.
BUT WHAT'S SO HARD TO UNDERSTAND
ABOUT THIS IS THAT FOR MONTHS
WE'VE BEEN GOING BACK AND FORTH
ABOUT WHAT REALLY HAPPENED WITH
DARREN WILSON AND MICHAEL BROWN
IN FERGUSON, MISSOURI.
DID BROWN HAVE HIS HANDS UP?
DID HE NOT HAVE HIS HANDS UP?
WAS WILSON AFRAID FOR HIS LIFE
WHEN HE KILLED BROWN?
REASONABLE PEOPLE --
AS WELL AS PLENTY OF (BLEEP)
ONES -- COULD --
OKAY, THEIR PICTURES DIDN'T COME
UP.
(LAUGHTER)
-- COULD REACH DIFFERENT
CONCLUSIONS.
BUT IN THIS CASE THERE WAS NO
AMBIGUITY.
EVEN WITH CLARITY THOUGH, PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO BLAME
THIS DEATH ON ANYTHING BUT THE
INJUSTICES OF A FLAWED SYSTEM.
>> WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND IS THAT MAN WAS
A BIG MAN.
>> HE'S A HUGE INDIVIDUAL.
>> GARNER OUTWEIGHED THE OFFICER
BY PROBABLY 150 POUNDS.
>> Jon: HE IS GIGANTOR! HE IS A
FLOAT IN A PARADE.
THEY HAD TO BRING HIM
DOWN!
HE WAS THE ABOMINABLE BRO MAN!
OK YEAH, HE OUTWEIGHED "ONE" COP
BY 150 POUNDS.
WHAT ABOUT THE OTHER FIVE COPS?
OR MAYBE THAT'S JUST HOW MUCH
RACIAL PROGRESS AMERICA HAS
MADE?
YOU KNOW, IT USED TO BE BLACK
PEOPLE WERE ONLY THREE-FIFTHS OF
A WHITE PERSON.
NOW, THEY'RE LIKE SIX!
UNLESS THERE'S SOME OTHER REASON
HIS SIZE WAS RELEVANT?
>> IF HE HAD NOT HAD ASTHMA AND
A HEART CONDITION AND WAS SO
OBESE, HE ALMOST DEFINITELY
WOULD NOT HAVE DIED FROM THIS.
THE POLICE HAD NO REASON TO KNOW
THAT HE WAS IN SERIOUS
CONDITION.
>> Jon: PLEASE...
ASTHMA, HEART DISEASE, OBESITY,
YEAH, THOSE ARE SERIOUS
CONDITIONS BUT, COME ON!
COME ON, THE MEDICAL EXAMINER'S
REPORT SAYS THAT GARNER DIED
FROM "COMPRESSION OF THE NECK"
AND "COMPRESSION OF THE CHEST."
THAT SOUNDS MORE LIKE DEATH BY
CHOKING THAN DEATH BY CHOCOLATE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
THE NYPD PATROL GUIDE DEFINES A
A CHOKEHOLD AS ANY PRESSURE TO
THE THROAT OR WINDPIPE
WHICH MAY PREVENT BREATHING OR
INTAKE OF AIR. WELL,
LISTEN TO ONE EXPERT EXPLAIN WHY
THIS CASE ISN'T THAT.
>> I WOULDN'T USE THE TERM
CHOKEHOLD AS A MARTIAL ARTITS
STUDENT, I WOULDN'T
USE THAT TERM.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: GO ON, SENSEI.
>> IF YOU GO FOR THE TRACHE
OR WHAT'S CALLED AN AIR CHOKE OR
THE WINDPIPE, YOU CAN LITERALLY
KILL SOMEBODY.
THAT'S ILLEGAL BY EVERY POLICE
DEPARTMENT STANDARD.
SO THE DEFINITIONS, IT MAY SOUND
TECHNICAL, BUT IT REALLY ISN'T
IN THIS CASE, IS IT?
>> Jon: NO, IT IS, MR. MIYAGI,
RESPECTFULLY.
THAT'S WHAT LITERALLY HAPPENED!
FACTS ON, FACTS OFF.
ALRIGHT, SO WE'VE ESTABLISHED
BUT INCREDIBLY FRAGILE, OUT OF
SHAPE MONSTER WEAKLING. AGAIN,
THEY WOULD JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW
AGAINST ALL AVAILABLE
CRIMINOLOGY STATISTICS THAT
EVERYONE IS EQUAL UNDER THE LAW.
>> PEOPLE SAY VERY CASUALLY THAT
THIS WAS DONE OUT OF RACIAL
MOTIVES OR OUT OF VIOLATIONS OF
CIVIL RIGHTS.
>> THERE'S NOT A HINT THERE THAT
ANYONE USED ANY RACIAL EPITHET.
>> Jon: SO, THE COPS HAVE TO USE
THE N-WORD FOR IT TO BE RACISM?
YOU'VE NEVER HEARD THE PHRASE A
PICTURE IS WORTH A THOUSAND
EPITHETS? I DON'T
KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT
THIS COP IS RACIST
BUT IT SEEMS THE ESCALATION OF
THESE INCIDENTS MAY
BE A BY-PRODUCT OF A SYSTEM
THAT'S APPLIED UNEQUALLY AND
WITH PREJUDICE.
BECAUSE IF IT'S NOT THAT, WHAT
IS IT?
>> IN THIS CASE, THE POLICE
OFFICER WAS DEALING WITH A
CRIMINAL WHO WAS RESISTING
ARREST.
MAYBE IF MR. BROWN HADN'T
COMMITTED HIS CRIMES AND THIS
GENTLEMAN HADN'T RESISTED
ARREST, THEY WOULDN'T BE
DEAD TODAY.
>> Jon: YEAH, OR IF THEY
DIDN'T CHOKE HIM.
I MEAN, NOT EVERYONE WHO
RESISTS ARREST -- YOU KNOW WHAT,
I THINK I CAN DO THIS.
THIS YOUR HONOR, MAY I APPROACH?
NOT THAT WE WERE HAVING A TRIAL,
OBVIOUSLY.
THAT'S WHAT THE GRAND JURY WAS
GOING TO TRY TO GET TO BE DONE.
BUT IF IT PLEASES THE COURT, I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE THAT
RESISTING ARREST DOESN'T ALWAYS
LEAD TO THIS SORT OF THING.
HERE'S EVIDENCE, EXHIBIT A.
>> COME ON.
>> GET OFF THE BEACH NOW.
>> GET THE (BLEEP) OFF MY ARM
BEFORE -- GET THE (BLEEP) OFF.
GET OFF!
>> FOR BEING A NUISANCE.
REALLY? I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
THERE WAS A CHARGE FOR THAT.
>> I'M A (BLEEP) GOOD PERSON!
>> WATCH YOUR HEAD, WATCH YOUR
HEAD.
>> Jon: YOU'RE TELLING ME SHE
WAS LESS OF A MENACE TO SOCIETY
AT THAT TIME?
NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT SHE'S
STRAIGHTENED HER LIFE OUT AND
HAS SHOWN US THAT SHE IS,
AND I'M QUOTING HERE, A
(BLEEP) GOOD PERSON, BUT -- COME
ON, PEOPLE, WON'T ANYONE ADMIT
THIS IS SYMPTOMATIC OF A LARGER
ISSUE?
>> JOINING ME NOW IS KENTUCKY
SENATOR RAND PAUL.
>> I THINK THERE'S SOMETHING
BIGGER THAN JUST THE INDIVIDUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> Jon: THANK YOU!
RAND PAUL!
YOU KNOW, HERE IS A REPUBLICAN
WHO HAS BEEN MAKING AN EFFORT TO
REACH OUT TO THE
BLACK COMMUNITY.
HE'S BEEN TALKING ABOUT VOTING
RIGHTS AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
SO THIS IS,THIS IS A START.
GIVE IT TO US STRAIGHT.
WHAT IS THE LARGER ISSUE HERE?
>> SOME POLITICIAN PUT A TAX OF
$5.85 ON A PACK OF CIGARETTES,
SO THEY'VE DRIVEN CIGARETTES
UNDERGROUND BY MAKING THEM SO
EXPENSIVE.
BUT THEN SOME POLITICIAN ALSO
HAD TO DIRECT THE POLICE TO SAY,
HEY, WE WANT YOU ARRESTING
PEOPLE FOR SELLING A LOOSE
CIGARETTE.
>> Jon: WHAT THE (BLEEP) ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT?
WELL, I GUESS NOW WE KNOW WHAT
IT TAKES FOR A SENATOR FROM
KENTUCKY TO ADMIT CIGARETTES CAN
KILL.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY!
I APPRECIATE THE PURITY OF YOUR
ANTI-TAX DOGMA, BUT THE
CIGARETTE TAX IS TRULY THE LEAST
SALIENT ASPECT OF THIS CASE!
IT'S LIKE SAYING, YOU KNOW THE
PROBLEM WITH THE HINDENBURG,
GOVERNMENT PARKING REGULATIONS.
THAT'S IT!
YOU KNOW, YOU'VE GOT BIG BROTHER
OVER YOUR SHOULDER GOING,
EVERYBODY'S GOT TO DOCK!
(LAUGHTER)
HONESTLY, ERIC GARNER COULD HAVE
BEEN OUT THERE WITH MIX
TAPES OR A A SQUEEGEE OR A
SNOWCONE AND THE SAME KIND OF
(BLEEP) COULD HAVE HAPPENED.
FOR THE SECOND TIME IN TEN
DAYS, A GRAND JURY, WHICH AT
LEAST IN FEDERAL CASES HAS A 99%
INDICTMENT RATE,
FAILED TO INDICT AN OFFICER WHO
CAUSED THE DEATH OF AN UNARMED
CITIZEN. THEY DIDN'T INDICT HIM
FOR ANYTHING.
NOT MURDER, NOT MANSLAUGHTER,
NOT EVEN RECKLESS ENDANGERMENT
WHICH IS LIKE ONE DEGREE
ABOVE A PARTY FOUL.
AND FOR SOME REASON TO QUESTION
A SYSTEM PRODUCING THAT RESULT
IS SOMEHOW OFFENSIVE.
>> THIS PROCESS HAS TAKEN PLACE.
IT'S OUR CONSTITUTION.
IT'S THE LAWS WE LIVE BY.
GET OVER IT.
>> THEY ARE TEARING DOWN RESPECT
FOR A CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
THAT GOES BACK TO ENGLAND IN THE
11th CENTURY.
>> Jon: SO DOES WITCH BURNING
AND (BLEEP) WHERE WE DRINK.
BUT WE'VE CONTINUED TO IMPROVE
UPON THOSE PROCESSES!
YOU KNOW, FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND, THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM HAS TWO SEPARATE BUT
EQUALLY IMPORTANT PARTS -- THE
POLICE WHO INVESTIGATE CRIMES
AND THE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS WHO
PROSECUTE!
(LAUGHTER)
OKAY.
I GOT THAT FROM TV.
GRAND JURIES ALMOST ALWAYS DO
WHAT THE PROSECUTOR WANTS.
SO MAYBE WE NEED TO LOOK AT WHEN
IT COMES TO THE POLICE IF
PROSECUTORS REALLY DON'T WANT TO
INDICT THEM BECAUSE THEY WORK
WITH THEM AND THEY NEED THEM AND
THEY'RE ON THE SAME SHOW WITH
THEM, THEY'RE COLLEAGUES, AND
THAT MAKES FOR A VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE SITUATION.
HEY, BEFORE I TRY AND SEND YOU
TO PRISON, THERE'S SOMETHING I
GOTTA ASK YOU -- THIS YEAR, ARE
YOU MY SECRET SANTA?
(LAUGHTER)
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.